tenemos espacio más un dieciseisavo es
igual a tres medios los animo a que
pausa en el vídeo y que tratan de
descubrir cuál es la fracción que falta
para que al sumarle un dieciseisavo sea
igual a tres medios bueno vamos a
trabajar juntos en esto una manera de
hacer esto más fácil para nuestros
cerebros es que expresemos un
dieciseisavo y tres medios con un
denominador común tenemos que buscar un
denominador común para estas fracciones
y por suerte el 16 es divisible entre 2
y es divisible entre 16 por supuesto así
que este es el denominador común de
hecho es el mínimo común múltiplo entre
16 y dos otros múltiplos comunes pero
este es el mínimo común múltiplo 16 por
1 y también es divisible entre 2 vamos a
reescribir esta ecuación pero con el
denominador común así que tenemos
espacio más un dieciseisavo
es igual a algo sobre 16 para pasar del
denominador 2 al 16 tenemos que
multiplicar por 8 así que también
tenemos que multiplicar el numerador por
8 entonces 3 por 8 es igual a 24 en este
punto ya debe ser capaz de resolverlo en
tu mente espacio más un dieciseisavo es
igual a 24 dieciseisavos sabemos que
este es un cierto número de
dieciseisavos así que cuantos
dieciseisavos más un dieciseisavo es
igual a 24 dieciseisavos
bueno pues 23 dieciseisavos si le
sumamos un 16 hago el resultado serán 24
dieciseisavos otra forma de pensar en
esto desde el primer paso es decir
espacio más un dieciseisavo es igual a
tres medios y esto es igual a espacio
es igual a tres medios
menos
un dieciseisavo esta es otra manera de
abordar el problema si espacio más un
dieciseisavo es igual a tres medios
entonces espacio es igual a tres medios
menos un dieciseisavo y sabemos que tres
medios es igual a 24 dieciseisavos
- un dieciseisavo
y esto es igual a 23 dieciseisavos
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
este es un poco diferente tengo espacio
menos tres cuartos es igual a dos
tercios y hay un par de formas de pensar
en esto espacio menos tres cuartos es
igual a dos tercios una forma de
resolverlo es espacio es igual a dos
tercios más tres cuartos dos tercios más
tres cuartos
y cuál es el resultado de esto una vez
más tenemos que reescribir estas
fracciones para que tengan un
denominador común y cuál es el mínimo
común múltiplo entre 3 y 4 bueno podemos
buscar los múltiplos de 4 e incrementar
los hasta encontrar uno que sea
exactamente divisible entre 3 4 no es
divisible entre 3 8 no es divisible
entre 3 12 si es divisible entre 3 3 por
4 es igual a 12 entonces podemos
reescribir esto como fracciones de 12 a
2 para pasar del 3 al 12 tenemos que
multiplicar por 4 así que vamos a hacer
lo mismo con el numerador 2 por 4 es
igual a 8 2 tercios es igual a 8
doceavos 8 doceavos +
que sobre 12 para pasar del 4 al 12
tenemos que multiplicar por 3 entonces
tenemos que multiplicar el numerador por
3 también 3 por 3 es igual a 9 y cuál es
el resultado de esto
8 12 ambos más 9 doceavos es igual a 17
doceavos 17 doceavos menos tres cuartos
es igual a dos tercios otra forma de
hacer esto es reescribir las fracciones
pero con un denominador común y sabemos
que el denominador común es 12 porque es
el mínimo común múltiplo entre 3 y 4
podría ser 24 pero vamos a usar el
mínimo común múltiplo para mantener esto
lo más sencillo que podamos y tres
cuartos lo podemos reescribir como 9 12
ambos espacio
- 9 12 a vos es igual a 8 12 a vos y
podemos suponer que este resultado es un
cierto número de 12 a vos así que
espacio doceavos menos 9 12 ambos es
igual a 8 12 a vos
así que si tengo espacio de algo menos
nueve de ese algo y eso es igual a ocho
de ese algo el resultado es 17 de ese
algo en este caso 17 12 ambos menos 9 12
ambos es igual a 8 12 a vos de cualquier
manera el resultado es 17 12 a vos para
nuestro espacio